Koby good morning how are you what's up
Dan are you doing man what time did you
get up today it's kind of normal to me
now man I've been doing that for a long
time this is pretty much normal to make
you better early I don't I don't even
have to set my alarm about I just wake
up at that point but what do you do when
you wake up what have you done so far
oh well I was lifting weights and my
daughter goes with me on like a day like
today she normally gets up early to try
about two three times a week and so we
went and we got a good workout in and
now their generation school can you see
already the personality traits maybe of
you as an athlete
with any of your daughter oh god yeah my
middle daughter is a maid she's like you
know you don't want to smile when she's
playing and oh she wasn't physical like
I'm like like Gigi what are you mad at
kid but your wife knows what's coming
then she knows what this is right she
can't just you can't stop with my wife
the same way too right so we're sitting
there playing and playing a board game
we're playing uno something like that
she's just as competitive so you know
our kids are getting from both sides do
you think they'll come a point when your
daughter can beat you'd basketball
shooting shooting she may be able to
beat me she's a really really good
shooter already when was the first time
you beat your dad was about like 13 13
14 years old and that usually doesn't go
over well with dad was he angry
well well here's the thing it kind of
you know those relationships are like
playing one-on-one in the backyard the
fun that you have to follow it all that
in the second you beat him in essence
that relationship is not happening
anymore
that experience does not happen anymore
so never clear you want to uh never get
that's it
do you still play pickup at all no no
interest no Ivan no I haven't played
competitively since the last game since
you go here's a question I thought of
yesterday if I said now you did both of
these but if I said you could only have
one on your resume you could get the
only 81 or you could get the 60 in your
last game you have to pick between those
two you only get one I probably go with
the 81 because we were like one game out
of making the playoffs that year so we
needed literally needed every single
game to get into the postseason so if we
had dropped that one I think we would
have been in serious jeopardy of missing
the playoffs that year so I'll go with
81 Reggie Miller and I got into a heated
discussion like he kept saying you're
gonna end your career with 60 and then
he put exclamation points on his text
message and I said but 81 exclamation
point that's come on
81 in reg there's no 60 on your last
game but we have these different debates
like people places in history like can
LeBron ever be in the category the same
sentence as Michael Jordan when did you
get to the point where you realized that
maybe the media wasn't gonna put you in
that same category or allow you to get
up there with with Michael or did they
like I've never tried to waste my energy
thinking about things that definitively
came out with you know like we just sit
here and debate
okay who's better Kobe or Michael or
applause other stuff the debate that you
blew on his face I'm not gonna waste my
energy until you develop a time capsule
where I can go back in time and face
Jordan 91 92 93
blind in that kind of time cats cats
will put us all in the same era
and they will see what's what but until
they don't like always late at yoga who
would you want to face in their prime if
you had that opportunity
your prime versus their prime michael
9100 you got the year no doubt about it
ok no doubt about it no doubt about it
how would that plan why do you think
it's gonna play out
yeah no we'd go at it Mike I've had
these conversations before where we
recently you sit around we talk about it
you know I say and I say 91 because
that's belt like the year where he was
really you know at his prime you know
physically mentally just felt like he
was just absolute bull in 91 so I would
I would love to see what that looks like
but you know how he is if anybody
challenges him like he comes right back
and you know so you guys did does he
give you grief about it or you know I'm
not necessarily a passive person when
it's entertaining when we're both really
creative trash talkers so we're talking
to Kobe Bryant he's got a new show it's
called detail it airs exclusively on
ESPN plus today give me an idea what
this is all about well the thing about
this this series it's really for
basketball purists and you know even
more so than that
it's for athletes for NBA athletes so
it's me looking at game film and
breaking it down from the perspective of
being one of the players right so if you
take James hard for example they're just
playing game water game to whatever game
I decide to pick if I was James how
would I be studying which took place in
Game two right what would I be watching
how would I be parent be preparing for
Game three and for the rest of the
series so that's what this series is how
would you guard James Harden depends
it really has it depends on the
teammates that I have
what our strengths and weaknesses are so
to go back to the olden on Lakers you
know we had a lot of lanes right so
defensively for us we would push him
right and you know we'd sit on that uh
we'd sit on that left hand and use our
length with myself you know Ariza Odom
Powell
and we blanket that shooting hand and
I'll allow get to a step backs and
things of that nature sound like a coach
here well I mean I've been around some
of the best coaches in the world my man
so at some point it's got to rub off and
you never gave any thought to be in a
coach a coach my daughter's team good
well I mean they're learning grammar
that's best food that's the key right
you'll have to learn we do run the trial
offices in a world like I will be sit
there right I'll be sit there I'll say
okay okay let's calm down let's run a
Center opposite top passers denied let's
go back door step and then dribble weave
with the guard coming out of the corner
and I'll god they're just executed Oh
would you want to play the triangle in
today's NBA yeah triangle thing that
that can be adapted right and so you
people have this perspective the
triangle being a locals offense
originally that's what it started but
again all you want is on the high post
and when you run it from a high post you
might up opening the entire middle floor
right and so you'll see remnant so that
with what San Antonio whatever in
championships you see that was going to
state where the floor is opened up
but the triangle gives you structure
right and from that structure is players
the ability to read the defense and now
that you can read the defense because
you know where your teammates are
supposed to be because of the structure
and then gives you the ability to make
adjustments and to read the defense
instead of going out there and just
simply playing and see it would manifest
itself by chance if you didn't have
Jordan to model yourself after to
whatever degree who would you have
had that person on your wall that you
said that's who I'm gonna be or I'm
gonna be better then well I was a
complete basketball geek right so it
parts of my game that I really modeled
after Michael but there were other parts
that I took from Jerry West Hakeem
Olajuwon Oscar Robinson Elgin Baylor
George Gervin Andrew Tony Sam Jones I
mean the list goes on and on so that
everybody everybody does like this is in
pieces of the game a little slant that
they all have and so what I would try to
do is study him and see why these walls
work and then go out in the backyard and
try them and then try to what I would
play against other kids and then see why
a word why it didn't work and so I was a
complete basketball nerd and so Michael
gets most of the credit but yeah I
really really really took from a lot of
the great fans were these another war
Reggie Miller said that you borrowed his
step-back move he he thought he was good
like I think you stole it I think is
what Reggie said did you steal you step
you did okay of course I did
so we played one on what we're doing the
show you remember that show he's a come
on if you use like rolled rules
challenge or something like that yeah
and Reggie and I would happen to be on
the show is like some you know kind of
guests type of thing and it was on a
basketball court up at UCLA and where
it's kind of a waste of time so I say
let's say what I want and we played and
I was able to look at that step back you
know kind of up close mm m61 now like
that right so I can't believe you had
two players that were really using a
step back before cane ridiculously
popular and I was Reggie Miller and
Latrell Sprewell and Latrell Sprewell
step back we used to jump back like six
feet and it was crazy like I'm looking
I'm guard I'm here next to you know like
he's in the paint and it takes one step
knee to the core she was three I'm like
[Laughter]
so you gotta learn man you got to learn
from those around you baby you got to
see what they do well and see if you can
use it in your day if if I allow you one
trophy on the man
of any of your trophies what do you what
do you have on that mantle good Tammi
award yeah that's what I thought
that's what I thought yeah am i doing
looking at all the nominees and I went
wait
Kobe's up for an Academy Award I'm like
yeah and then you want and I go damn
Kobe's getting Academy Award right like
what the hell like oh my wife oh dear
basketball like I just wanted to write
something to the game and then once I
went through the process of making an
animation film and I called Glen and I
called John because I oh my god Glenn's
gonna do it oh my god John is gonna do
with it and then you you know we kind of
start putting the process together the
pieces together animation is amazing
that John's music they're like whoa this
is pretty cool nominations come out
you're like whoa then we went in it's
like wait a minute where is the Academy
Award
it's sitting in my office here at the
house and I have it sitting there right
next to the Andy award to another Emmy
Award and the Oscar in it so you know I
look at it every morning before I leave
to go to the studio how nervous were you
that night you know it's different kind
of nerves because I can basketball
you're competing directly against
someone so you have an impact on the
outcome all right when it comes to the
arts you don't know what cells are being
created in the world right so there's no
direct competition so you have no room
to really think about that you just
think about creating finding the nature
of the piece and trying to have the
piece live up to its fullest potential
like it's true right and then when
you're sitting at the Academy Awards I
mean there's it's already been decided
like this is out of your control right
so it's a different kind of nervous
movies I guess on the horizon yeah so
what will happen so detail which is uh
without now Sal analogous tm+ and after
that we uh we have a children's
podcaster is gonna be really
really fun for families to really enjoy
and late July and and then in March of
18 will be releasing our first novel and
we have a series of them coming out
probably will probably at least about
three a year on the first gonna be a
march of eighteen which is they're all
set around sports fantasy sports magic
and yeah we're really excited
I got Andre Ingram he's joining us in
the final or the show what okay but Kobe
how why did it take a guy that good at
three-point shooting ten years to get
into the league it makes you makes you
question somebody is in a league that's
it yeah Paulie do we have how many
points is Andre Ingram behind Kobe yeah
Andre as is 33600 19 points behind Kobe
on the all-time Laker scoring okay to do
but he's off to a great start you know
his first game was better than fine what
do you remember about that first game I
didn't play what do you remember about
the first game you played no I was blue
to the bench that's what that was um but
no I drew Ingram and with a story and
you know being able to have the
determination to stay with that dream
you know for ten years now that believed
that conviction that's glad and then
they get the opportunity and to not
capitulate to that practice nothing like
you're chasing something for ten years
and now that moments here that pressure
can get to people and then I mean he
just stepped right into that light man
and off you went so this is just the
beginning for him no it's incredible
hey one of these mornings when you're
not doing anything and you hear Reggie
Miller on the show I'd love for you to
call in just so you know you can you can
rough up reg a little bit any of this
stuff like you know how competitive like
he's like you know Kobe stole that from
me and he's always got his stories about
Jordan how he and Jordan got into a
fight and you know
so here if you ever you know you ever
get it you know I'm like 10 minutes and
you can rough up reg we'd love to have
you I appreciate that man hey good luck
with all the all the business ventures
there that's a great stuff in detail
appreciate am I gonna catch up with you
Thank You Koby that's Kobe Bryant detail
in collaboration with ESPN it debuts
today exclusively on ESPN plus for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]